I don't and I love your forehead we
understand thank you yes
so this Jonathan let's go to the let's
promote your job the amazing job you've
already put is it on so it is available
now on YouTube on the all things comedy
channel and it's just I know how much
you love documentaries love them so you
should watch this going to I sent you
the link you didn't watch it so this is
a documentary the amazing Jonathan great
comedian magician Game of Thrones that
finally is coming I'll watch this it's
deep burn doctor and come on man there's
things going on I'll watch it I watched
season one of animal practice you in the
little monkey commercial what I love I
know that wouldn't this happen okay so
Jonathan Vegas headline are one of the
first guys to pop off Comedy Central
like the Freddy Krueger of comedy and
magic he's just a rock star right five
years ago he was given a terminal
diagnosis he's diagnosed with
cardiomyopathy and told he has a year to
live so he retires from performing he
retires from the stage you combine
cardiomyopathy with drug addiction and
diabetes and the doctors say you have a
year to live get your affairs in order
and Jonathan does he retires he outlives
expectations and decides I'm going to
make return the stage and see if I still
have it if I can still perform so I
thought what a great impetus into a
documentary to go through his legacy in
his career and to see if he can still do
it but Jonathan was one of the first
guys ever featured four on the road and
I know his old road manager Joel Osborne
while Jonathan was touring the world and
popular in Australia for example outside
the door was his twelve year old kid who
saw his show and was enamoured with him
and every year he'd come back the kid
would be backstage can you sign this can
you son is 14 15 16 and then eventually
Jonathan gave him like a responsibility
hey I got a I have a tour here you want
to manage the tour while I'm gonna straw
yeah yeah of course
Joel turns 18 he says do you want to
come to the United States of America and
be my road manager Joe says absolutely
and from there it's like Rick and Morty
I mean these two should
not be in each other's lives but for
there's this fraternal relationship that
develops between them and again
Jonathan's drug addict suicide attempt
all this crazy [ __ ] that he put Joel
through and Joel kept him on track and
basically kept him alive Wow Joel gets
Jonathan's life on track post this awful
divorce gets him in a good place goes to
Australia becomes a comedian on his own
and then when Jonathan makes a return to
stage Joel comes back to open form so
it's this wonderful kind of heartwarming
documentary but you have all that on
there it's all in there oh my god now
and that's amazing and you produced it
right produced directed it oh my God all
the archival footage and stuff and it's
it's truly like a love letter to his
legacy to his career to all the great
bits that he's done but also to just an
unorthodox relationship that I think I
don't know it's nice to get away from
the TV and watch something I think
positive there yeah from politics how
was Jonathan doing now you know he I
think he has his good days and he's got
his bad days still with us right he's
still with us soon and I hope I up to
god he's with us for a long time but you
know III just don't know I don't know
how much longer yeah it's so funny
because there's a lot of guys like that
in comedy that like even the guys that
would didn't make it as big as amazing
Jonathan that like influenced me who I
love sure right and um I like the fact
that you open for this guy right back in
the day yeah and you're paying it
forward but it's also a really cool
story it's sad right but yeah we were
all happy and get the happy ending
yeah wow that's really cool man I will
watch it yeah I know I thought it was
literally just about here's you know him
on The Tonight Show smashing a pumpkin
with Gallagher and I'm like yeah I mean
I didn't know it was that that's cool
yeah III you know the reception we've we
played it a few festivals we want a few
best docs and stuff oh wow but I think
when you're in the business side of
things and you're allotted the decision
to you know see us a nominal return on
your on the money spent or the
visibility and hopefully people seeing
it my decision was I want as many people
to see this as possible especially for
Joel and Jonathan it's just a no so
listen up hearing what everyone
listening
honestly though I know this this podcast
has been I love it
but um you know and we don't know this
caption little hatchet and all that
stuff right but if I sort of [ __ ] out
at the end of the day this dude right
here his family and he's my brother
and um he's also your very proactive
yeah that's so inspirational you're just
constantly doing [ __ ] dude and you know
I'm the laziest guy everyone knows but
um you know I wish I could have some of
your you know but um you work all at the
time but listen everyone listening right
now get the documentary watch it support
it because it's a great idea
the amazing Jonathan is a legend Yeah
right he really is because he infused
you know how sometimes magicians well
yeah no you're right magicians are just
magicians right yeah and then they do
comedy but it's not funny yeah it's like
corny
yeah they have one-liners right but the
amazing Jonathan I remember watching him
going oh this guy's funny like he's
genuinely like guttural funny you know
says he's a better comedian than it is a
magician yeah but then we like
interviewed Copperfield and you know
Penn Jillette so there's like real
experts you know dissecting his act and
telling you exactly what what is
Copperfield's gonna look like I'll tell
you what he's a beautiful man
like I like I was sitting next I was
like man that's what it's like to be a
billionaire like he looks wealthy he
looks like a billionaire like the can
probably right is nice
he just looks great right like Jeff
Goldblum you have a recent obsession
I've been I've been googling his images
yeah and it's weird if you look at my
Google history every other one is Jeff
Gould in like Hawaiian shirts deep v's
yeah yeah because Kevin Christi Kevin
Christi about six months ago was talking
about Jeff Kilgore but a style okay that
guy no he's the best style for his age
he's really good looking for you know
you know this and that I looked at it
and I've been looking at every year I
think that he is he was dude let me say
something it he
is a good actor great actor yeah right
but he's stylish as [ __ ] wrong because
of his frame yeah he can wear like
longer stuff right that I could look kid
Ian right like button ups that I can't
wear and he's kind of Mediterranean
looking I don't know what easy Jew I
don't know what he is but he's
definitely yeah he's gonna bet Bennett
rien ba boom
he's also with um but he also um is
always with younger women I mean that's
his vibe yeah right there just something
magical about him um you know I'm not
gay I don't and even if I did like I'm
not I was sure gonna fly to him in his
Hyundai Santa Fe guys I'm not gay the
fly too even if I was on the flight too
yeah and he was like hey man let's
cuddle it up whatever I be nah brah well
you know Kevin Christie did our poster
art for a Mason Jonathan we're always
well I think Kevin's a phenom I mean
obviously he's posting his artwork on
he's phenomenal he did my third hour
special champion he painted that thing
and then for always amazing work I mean
dude I am a number one Kevin Christie
I'm the one that got him into comedy
really I did an ampm commercial okay
yeah and it was four guys walking into
an ampm and Kevin was the leader of the
four guys and I was in the four guys we
just walk into an ampm we then he sent
round of group oh my god and the guy
behind the counter was the alpha male
yeah and we were the Nerds yeah okay but
then when we were but then I ran into
him an amoeba and he goes let me come
check out your comedy so he came to the
comedy store and then it took him a year
yeah and he finally called me he goes I
want to try it so we set it all up put
him on open mic on this 90 and he opened
for me that's Twitter by the way he's
one of the cast's that I love her
Twitter too you know so secondly he did
the Kings of Leon's one of the first
ever the guy's a legitimate artist he's
a great stand-up here's the last thing
that he can do he can act his [ __ ]
ass off yeah he's a great actor
this kid is everything yeah everything
he has everything this kid
look up Kevin Christe